[Music]
even a visit to the grocery store can
overload the senses it's noisy bright
and smelly
the nose is working overtime high up
inside specialized nerves dangled in the
Airstream they detect chemicals in the
air and send an electrical signal to the
brain which interprets the signals as
smells the nerves are super sensitive
every smell is a new sensation
the same goes for our hearing strange
new world strange new sounds
sound waves vibrate the eardrum on the
other side of the eardrum these tiny
bones the ossicles vibrate in response
they're the smallest bones in the body
but without them we would never hear a
thing they use leverage to amplify the
vibrations hitting the eardrum 22 times
[Music]
the amplified vibrations now enter the
inner ear or cochlea it's lined with
delicate hairs when vibrations pass
through the hairs vibrate at the base
are the fragile hairs for high-frequency
sounds at the top low frequency hairs
each one 200 times thinner than a hair
on our head
over time loud noises will damage these
hairs but at this age they're perfect
our hearing will never be this good
again the story is different for
eyesight we're born with very
underdeveloped vision even at one month
the world is blurred and mostly black
and white every aspect of our vision is
rudimentary the eye muscles are immature
keeping us from pointing our eyes where
we want to inside the eye the lens
muscles still can't focus and the lens
flips the image it receives all through
life we see the world upside down the
picture only gets reoriented in our
brains right now the picture is on the
retina the screen at the back of the eye
the retina has two types of cells rods
and cones which transform the light that
hits them into electric signals the
cones detect color information but
because they're not developed yet we see
mostly in black and white during our
first month
from the retina the signals travel along
too thick nerves under the brain at the
back is where we process visual
information when the image arrives the
real challenge begins our immature
brains haven't learned to interpret the
data yet that's changing fast